[Music]
so
[Applause]
[Music]
hello i'm nicholas thompson i'm the
editor-in-chief of wired
welcome to day two of wired25 every time
i see that video
i've now seen it a couple times it makes
me nostalgic nostalgic for the time we
could all sit with
chris evans and susan wojcicki and
johnny ives and
killer robots and now
we're all kind of being beamed in like
edward snowden
in that trailer it's a moment where
we all crave real human connection but
this is the best we can do these
conferences these conversations
and we had a fabulous fabulous one last
week we've got a fabulous
fabulous lineup today so i'd like to
thank
our sponsor vonage for making this
possible i'd like to thank you all
for being here and i think we're going
to have i think we're going to have a
really good program
the theme last week was culture cultural
icons
a lot of the conversation as i mentioned
at the end centered around empathy
using our art and our work to understand
other people
to show people what we do to help
connect
the world in a way that counters
all the different ways that we're
getting fractured and split apart
the theme this week is similar but
different
it's resilience it's the ability to
withstand all these pressures and this
is
a perfect week to be doing it because
this is the week we honor ruth vader
ginsburg who
as we do this is lying in state in
washington dc
and if there's any word that encompasses
her life it's resilience
you know her many years working in the
law for many years
as a justice all that she overcame she
famously said that
in any good marriage it helps to be a
little deaf i take constructive
criticism but
when something gets a little loud when
something is a little obnoxious when
something is trying to distract you
you just keep pressing ahead and you
keep pressing forward and she did that
until the very end of her life so it is
the perfect theme
resilience for today we have a whole
bunch of conversations
about resilience and tech making our
community stronger making everything
about our lives stronger
we're going to kick it off sarah fryer
and lauren good
so let's begin there over to you lauren
anyone know a babysitter we do
i got you i'm looking for a handyman i
know a good guy for a fence
can someone help us fix our water heater
i can help with that anyone know a good
gardener yeah i got one where can i find
a decent cupcake around here i'm going
to delight by don after this
don makes the best cupcakes anyone
hungry
delicious looking for the best on your
block tap into your neighborhood
[Music]
wow look at all the people without masks
like nick i kind of feel a little bit
nostalgic for those times for sure that
video must have been recorded in the
four times
i'm lauren good i'm a senior writer at
wired i'm also the host of the new get
wired podcast and i'm absolutely
thrilled to be welcoming
sarah fryer to our virtual wire25 event
this year
sarah has a long impressive career in
tech and finance
she's worked for goldman sachs
salesforce she was the chief financial
officer of square for several years
and now she is the chief executive of
nextdoor
she also sits on the boards of walmart
and slack
sarah thank you so much for joining me
today um in our virtual
environments lauren thank you it is such
a delight and i too was having the same
feelings of nostalgia
um of getting together in real life and
that's what we all love about our
neighborhoods
absolutely and in years past of course
we would do this event in real life but
now we're doing this and we hope to
bring you some really great programming
and some great conversations so for
those of you who don't know what we just
saw was an
ad for next door and there are probably
some people listening who
aren't on nextdoor or are a little bit
familiar with it
the comparison i most often hear when
people say what is nextdoor
someone says well it's kind of like
facebook for your neighborhood
and i think that has a lot to do with
the the design of it you know the fact
that it's a
new but i would love to hear your
thoughts on that comparison
and particularly how you feel being
compared to facebook in a time when our
relationship with facebook is a little
bit
fraught sure so for those of you not
using nextdoor nextdoor is the
neighborhood hub
it is the place to go to tap into what's
going on locally
and of course we know that local has
never been more important as people are
staying at home working from home
and have seen so much of the need to
reach out during this crisis
to the people that live around them next
door is the way to do that so if you're
not on the platform
please come join us in terms of the
comparison to other social media
platforms
we do think we're very different our
purpose at nextdoor is to cultivate a
kinder world where everyone has a
neighborhood to rely on and so we really
think of ourselves
as the humane platform the place where
people are really coming together for
good in order to do that
we are bringing together people who
don't already know each other it's a
very different graph so it's not your
friend graph
it's not your professional graph it is
literally the people who
have what they have in common with you
is proximity
um and in times of crisis that's
actually incredibly important
because those are the people that can
show up at your door and go grab a
prescription
and there are people like me who have
are privileged to be healthy
who can go out and go to the supermarket
for say an elderly neighbor
and we think it's important that you're
not in a thought bubble you are
literally meeting people who are very
diverse
and different from you and sharing
opinions
and starting to get garner empathy for
one another
and one of the things that you've said
in the past too is that one of the
differentiators is that you
authenticate people in a different way
when they join the platform you're
verifying them
in a certain way talk a little bit about
how that happens and also
ultimately how you grow a business
like that when there are these
intentional barriers put up to people
joining the community yes so
we always say next door was founded in
trust so as you just noted
we do take the time to verify that
you're a real person
at a real address there's no bots
there's no fake people no avatars or
trolls
because you're really there with your
real name and that's important because
that starts to build trust and
accountability
so that that is a big part of our ethos
you're right that there are times when
we will take the road less trodden so it
isn't just growth at
any cost it's very intentional growth
there are other parts of our platform
where we intentionally slow people down
in fact as we see conversations get more
heated
we often will interject something called
our kindness reminder
it's a piece of technology that we
worked on with a bunch of
amazing social scientists to effectively
slow people down
often when they're here in this part of
their brain dinosaur brain
and bring them back up to their frontal
cortex where they can think
and really work through those biases and
we think it's
so important never be more important in
fact at a time when people are quite
stressed and so therefore potentially
more on edge easier to trigger that we
are reminding them
that great neighborhoods are created
with kindness so those are just two
examples of things we do
that often slow down growth but we think
it's intentional and good growth and
we're still in
268 000 neighborhoods in 11 countries so
it certainly hasn't held us back
right and what you've said uh in recent
interviews is that you have seen a fair
amount of growth on the platform since
the pandemic started
uh presumably because people are looking
to their neighbors for resources and
that sort of thing
but i'm glad you brought up that idea of
slowing down in fact
wire did a story on next door back in
about some of the design changes that
next door was making to try to slow
people
down in particularly when it came to
racial profiling right there had been
activities spotted particularly in the
crime and safety section
of the website where people were racial
profiling and
it's a it's a very real problem on the
platform as it is on
many other platforms and so next door as
i understand it instituted these
mechanisms to basically get people to
stop and say hey wait a second are you
sure you want to post that
and now that it's been a few years and
particularly when society is still so
divided and divisive
how are you measuring whether or not
that's working how do how do you measure
the success of these tools yes
great questions because of course we can
all make ourselves feel good
by doing things but are we actually
showing real material results and as you
point out
that division and divisiveness and
things like racial profiling
are problems in society and so they will
expose themselves onto
virtual environments too if you take
something like racial profiling
so for start we've even changed the name
we only talk about safety now we've
removed the word crime because we think
that triggers a particular thought
process
we worked with some great academics
including dr jennifer eberhardt out of
stamford
if you all haven't read her book biased
at a minimum listen to her ted talk
because she talks exactly about the
science behind slowing people down
and so as we've measured that impact
since 2015
we now see that 75 percent less
posts are made with and with racial
profiling in them
and then of course from there we have we
of course moderate uh to make sure that
no post any post is is obviously a miss
and so we want to make sure it's not
happening other examples
um we've put in place a neighborhood
pledge recently
really reminding people that nextdoor is
a community guideline
platform where you do agree coming to
our platform that you'll be helpful not
hurtful for example or that there's no
place for hate speech or racism
and just that sign up is often a way
that a human will
remember oh i'm supposed to act in a
certain way
and then beyond the kind of stick
there's also the carrot
right we don't just want to tell people
what not to do it's actually often
far more important to norm people to the
positive what is it that works well here
and what do i get rewarded for and so
being able to use
actions like a like or a thank you we
often will use personalization
to move posts that are really deeply
meaningful neighbors
to neighbors up the stack and as we
create products like groups
we're able to also augment here are the
types of groups that are working well in
your neighborhood
i literally just prior to this was
listening to a neighbor
talking about her walking group in
manhattan it's a women's only
walking group but she talked about the
camaraderie for someone who'd moved from
the midwest
was quite young in her 20s and really
just missed human human interaction so
they're
socially distanced walking with masks on
but for her it was all about the
conversation and finding some connection
people are lonely people are anxious and
they really are trying to find
new ways to come together and you can
only do that
in in an in real life neighborhood way
because you've got to live near people
if you're going to walk with them
right that makes a lot of sense um so it
sounds like you're seeing
some measure of success based on some of
the changes you've made around racial
profiling
um and i'm wondering what it is you
would say to
folks who are still a little bit
hesitant to be on nextdoor
or particip maybe they're on but they
don't want to participate
because they see a lot of uh divisive
or problematic content or outright
racist content that may be
extremely upsetting to them what's
what's sort of your
what's your best answer to that right
now for people who are still a little
bit resistant to the idea
of it sure so i would first of all give
it a try
con for the community right people often
arrive with a utilitarian
um something to fall i need a plumber i
want to know the best place to grab
coffee locally um i'd love a play date
for my kids a lot of people are
struggling right now with kids at home
but stay for the community and the
connectedness actually start to see that
blossom
and we know what's happening in
neighborhoods right across those 11
countries
in terms of you know if you are
uncomfortable know
that we are moderating so we use local
leads and now local community reviewers
one of the things we heard really in the
depths of what was going on
around black lives matter right after
george floyd's killing
was that people wanted to have more
moderation and they really wanted to see
the diversity of their community
in those moderators and so we've
actually just launched a new program
called community reviewers
i have been wowed by how many people
have put their hand up to be a community
reviewer
and one thing we know for sure is the
more that we get
newer members into those community
reviewer roles
the better because newer members tend to
be much more representative
of their community at large rather than
say maybe our founding members
we love them too but we love that our
newer members tend to be more
representative
so we think next door has changed a lot
for the better even in the last couple
of years
so if you've tried us before maybe come
back and take a look again
because your neighborhood needs you
sorry about that my cat just decided to
join my cat wants to be a part of the
community
and we find a lot of them
yeah you want to know what's going on
with the neighborhood cats so um
so you bring up content moderators which
is a really important topic these days
and you probably saw recently that
youtube after saying back in march was
going to rely a little bit more on ai
to moderate some problematic content
just went back
to humans it turns out humans were very
valuable
uh in the jobs that we do and so i'm
wondering what you think and it sounds
like you're relying heavily on
on humans too people in the community to
moderate
content so i'm wondering what you see
the future of
content moderation being on platforms
like yours like
do we swing back towards ai once the
technology gets better
um do content moderators finally become
a you know a value a valued and highly
paid role
in technology what does the future look
like
sure so we view it as a layered cake and
there's three layers in my cake right
now
the first is where i started which is
that moderation happens at a local level
and we think it's really important
because only the people who live in that
neighborhood
actually have local context right it's
very hard to imagine how
a company in silicon valley could
possibly be moderating my dad's
neighborhood
in northern ireland with no context for
what it's really like to live in that
rural community
so that's kind of step one and as i said
we're broadening those roles
so today a lot of the focus is content
moderation
but our leads also um fulfill many other
roles like they're often the welcome
wagoner
they're often the person that might get
a community together around say local
businesses
so we're also expanding how we think
about roles over time so that's kind of
layer one
layer two is technology um i never want
to say technology is the solution to all
ills
but it can have a very scalable part to
pay play
and so clearly we do use machine
learning to be able to spot
um for example when a conversation is
starting to heat up
a machine can spot quickly but that's
happening so
things like sentences get shorter they
start
losing all punctuation often they might
move to all caps for example
and that might be a great time to remind
mid flight
a to slow down so interest interest that
interject something like our kindness
reminder
but it might also be a great time to
suggest a group because we know that for
some people
they are really really kind of about
civic engagement
in their local neighborhood but not
everyone wants to talk about the new
zoning law
and so that's the kind of technology
might flip you over into a group for
example
and then of course the third layer of my
three-layer cake is internal moderation
at next door
we have a neighborhood operations team
and in particular for maybe some of the
the most controversial topics things
like discrimination and racism
they go directly to our neighborhood
operations team
because we want to make sure the people
that are perhaps most sophisticated in
that review
are taking a look at content that could
be most problematic so
always more to do it's a journey it's
like security
um which i used to cover a lot like when
i was an analyst at goldman sachs
you are never done the fraudsters or the
people that want to create a division
will always keep finding ways around and
to do more but our job is to stay ahead
of them
and frankly to keep bringing back to
neighborhoods that feeling of kindness
and that feeling of why
when neighborhoods are strong really
good things happen
what would you say is the most
interesting thing that you've learned
about
people on nextdoor during the pandemic
yeah you know it's a great question
i'm actually going to go back
pre-pandemic where i literally went to
every country that we are in um or i
went to 10 out of 11. i didn't go to
italy unfortunately which is a miss
and what i heard that surprised me is
actually a little negative i heard a lot
of people talking about loneliness and
social isolation
and it wasn't just say seniors in a
community or
say a young mom who for the first time
is home with a baby
it was coming across every neighbor
almost that i met with regardless of age
or
whether they worked or didn't work male
or female and so
that actually started a lot of research
and work that we've now continued
through the pandemic
we are currently surveying neighbors in
australia the uk
and the us i'm working frankly with some
of the best academics on this topic of
loneliness and social isolation
one of the first findings is that if you
know
six neighbors or more hopefully but six
is the magic number
you are much less likely to suffer from
that
feeling of being isolated or that
anxiety that comes with it
so turns out neighbors are good for your
health
and it also does align with our former
surgeon general
vivek murthy um came up with the best
tagline which is loneliness is the
equivalent of smoking
15 cigarettes per day so i do think that
there is going to be a global trend
particularly through covet because we're
having our own social experiment right
now
being trapped in our own little boxes
without a lot of
real human to human connection about
just the negative impact that can have
and how we all need to kind of fight the
other way local is an easy fast way to
do it because you can literally go for a
walk
you know down your street in manhattan i
can hit
a more suburban community here where i
live and even if it's as simple as a
quick wave or a greeting
that can really make a difference in
someone's life if they're struggling
with anxiety and social depression
absolutely sarah i think we only have a
few minutes left
and some audience questions that i
wanted to ask you i may only be
able to get to one of them um and by the
way i knew that best of next door the
twitter account told me to tell you
hello
for those of you who don't know what
festive next store is i recommend you go
check it out check it out
because they share some of the more
interesting next door stories on twitter
let's ask this question coming from cruz
alvarado
and thank you for sending in your
question cruz how do you see the
political landscape
impacting your decisions on future
projects this is a great question
because we talked about divisiveness and
we talked about racism
um we didn't specifically talk about
politics of course that's top of mind
for a lot of people right now
yeah cruz thank you it's a great
question and something i'm spending a
lot of time on as you can imagine
with the u.s election and clearly even
last year with brexit in the uk it was
very top of mind for our uk neighbors
first of all we should probably just
make clear that we don't allow
conversations around national
politics in the main news feed on next
door we just find it got
too divisive too controversial so we
actually ask the neighbors take that
over
into a group and they can found their
own group to talk about it or probably
find a group
where people do want to talk national
politics on the other side we think
local politics actually has a really big
place on nextdoor
we know that often people come together
in their community because they want to
be
civically minded or civically active
and in fact that's one of the things
that tends to fall away when communities
no longer strengthen what are called
weak ties
so you're not able to get a group
together to say hey we want to put
you know traffic cones on this road
because our kids are playing here and
we'd like to slow down the traffic
and so we do want that to be a very
healthy part of next door
and in fact i think it's one of the huge
utilities that neighbors get
out of it so it's an interesting um
nuance of how do we ensure national
moves off into a group
but local can really stay in the main
news feed
because for many people there's no local
news anymore no newspaper to go to
so it can be the way that they're
finding finding out about
what's going on with say the local mayor
we also work with a lot of public
agencies to make sure the most
recent and the best information is
really top of mind
and that can be everyone from say
governor newsom here in california
the mayor of london mayor khan all the
way to fema
right now we have a lot of tropical
storms and hurricanes moving either
through texas or up the east coast
we have wildfires here in california and
that's a really important place for
government and often politicians to be
involved
because they're actually providing
providing information that keeps
neighborhoods safe
that makes a lot of sense i will say
that um the wildfires have been one of
the instances where
nextdoor has been helpful during these
times um
but it's interesting you talk about sort
of creating a section for national
politics i feel like we could have a
whole other conversation
about that at some point um but i have
to wrap this up
because we have other great wire 25
programming to get to so
sarah fryer ceo of nextdoor thank you so
much for joining me today in this
virtual wire25 event
thank you lauren really appreciate it
good morning good afternoon my name is
arielle pardes i'm a senior writer with
wired
and i am joined today by arlen hamilton
the founder and managing partner of
backstage capital
and katie ray the ceo and managing
partner of
the engine welcome to both of you
thank you i could not have asked for two
better people to talk to you today about
my favorite topic in tech which is
the money um we're going to be talking
about how
we build the stuff that matters which
often comes down to
funding the stuff that matters and that
is where both of you come in
so arlen i want to start with you you
founded backstage capital almost
exactly five years ago and the mission
was to
invest in underestimated founders
so i want to ask what that word means to
you and
what kind of opportunity you saw in
these underestimated founders that
other investors weren't seeing
sure so uh yeah we celebrated five years
uh a week ago
today um we uh so underestimated is
actually a term that was gifted to me by
one of our founders
uh three years ago during our second
year anniversary
and uh it really is it just speaks to
the difference between um thinking of
black and brown founders and women in
general
at founders as a charity or competition
and what we want to be what we want
people to
to hear when they hear underrepresented
or underestimated
is that's your competition that someone
or a group of people who
have been overlooked and discounted
but it's not to say that they're not on
on par with you or
and maybe in some cases even beyond
your your reach um and are lapping you
in fact
and so seven or eight years ago when i
was looking into
the world of silicon valley and other
tech hubs which were few and far between
at the time
when i came across the statistic that 90
of venture funding
goes to straight white men and they make
up a third of the country
it didn't make any sense to me and so i
start looking around as a gay black
woman
thinking well first first thought was
that
sucks because uh where does that leave
me but then it
it really quickly turned into what an
opportunity
what a uh what a gift that um so many
people are overlooking us and taking
and taking us for granted to be honest
and so
my my thought was if we have done so
much with so little as i've seen
so many of us do what would happen if we
were given more
if we we had that slight uh uh
chance that was not afforded to us prior
and so uh first i went out asking people
to do this and then once i realized i
was it was falling on deaf ears i said
i'll attempt it myself and so i put
together a few million dollars from
from scratch to do that over the years
i love that idea if people have been
working on
so little because they're so
underestimated what would happen
if you gave them more and i want to
return to that concept because i think
it's really powerful
um but katie you're also reaching a
slightly different set of founders and
companies with your fund
the engine though um as i understand it
your
founders and companies often need more
to do more
they need more upfront capital they need
more time in their development cycles
and so i want to ask you the same
question what was the
opportunity that you saw as an investor
in taking a chance on some of the
companies that you've invested in
yeah so if you take a look at what the
engine does
we back really transformational
technology
that could shape a market and solve a
you know huge world problem all in a go
right and but it requires patience
it requires capital and it requires
imagination
on how to get these types of companies
to market
right it's not just straight software
so if you're gonna change the world's
energy grid to be
carbon free you know you only have a few
transformational technologies that could
work to do that
so you have to reach back into
uh you know the best universities in the
world we were partnered with mit
and look at how could that happen
and then back founders to do that but it
means that your time frames to market
are often you know ten years not
two or one or zero and it means that you
could
potentially be having to raise you know
a hundred million dollar first round
not one to two so that means that you
have to be
creative about the capital raising
creative about how to back companies
like this
but the opportunity the economic
opportunity
is enormous but you have to have the
wherewithal
to pull that all together and so that's
what we do at the engine
and you know we back founders coming out
of phd
programs post docs professors who have
created these real breakthroughs
across many many industries whether it's
decarbonization of the energy grid or
how we can
truly extend human life in meaningful
ways
to a very large set of the population
or how we're better connected so we
think of that as advanced systems
all of those are really important for
our planet
and under under invested in because
they look more complex or it's not in
the
regular playbook but we just are
we're psyched that we have that
opportunity and we think we'll make a
ton of
progress for the planet but also returns
for our investors
i'm very glad that you brought that up
because um
neither the engine nor backstage capital
are charities
you are not philanthropists you are
investors and
so you're investing in people and
companies that you think will make a
difference but you're doing so to get
returns
and we often see investors especially in
venture capitals
sidestepping the kinds of founders and
startups that you are
interested in because they fear that
they won't make
money i actually just saw this week the
global head of technology at deutsche
bank was quoted saying
rarely in my investment career do i see
what's good for society
is also good for investment returns and
so i wanted to ask each of you
what is wrong with that perspective what
have you seen through your funds that
proves that maybe
you actually can make money by investing
in diversity investing in social good
investing in
tech that changes the world
um one thing to note when it comes to
venture
is i think just in the last month or so
they released some someone released uh
data i think it was pitch book or
crunchbase that said
something like two-thirds of all venture
funds return
1x or less over their seven to ten year
period and so
one one way of framing it is that you
know
being safe so far is not really working
be uh if for no other reason
uh getting outside of the of the you
know
color lines uh no pun intended
is uh is interesting
competitive or who looks at trends or
you know in the same way that people
look at you know
other trends uh like cryptocurrency and
things like that
you know just take a just to take an
academic
uh uh critical look at it rather than
dismissing it all in and then of course
anecdotally
i'm surrounded by people surround
absolutely surrounded by people
in our portfolio more than 100 companies
so
250 300 founders total
who have been overlooked and i believe
a good 20 of them will go on to
either in this company or the next
lead uh unicorn companies if they if
they want to
they're they're um creating impact
now and and we're talking about what is
it 20
what is the 2030 or 24 i don't know
exactly right now but
at some point we're going to be a
majority minority and so
we're going to have to speak to we have
to start now to speak to that audience
and it just um
the past 10 years everything that that
black and brown people who have been
paying attention have predicted has come
true and i think this year is like a
culmination of that it's come to a head
and to to overlook it now is is just
at the investors peril
and maybe one thing to add to that
totally agree
is that you know if you
if you talk to people the young people
of today
just go out to the universities and you
know
people of every race class
gender what you
hear so often is
we want to do good and
so if you just follow the youth in what
will
be they want to be on a mission
that is good for our planet good for
other people
you're gonna make money by being aligned
i'm sorry the youth always know
so you just sound old when you say that
yeah you know when you say oh oh yeah
you can't make money by doing good
you're just old
right
you also can't make money if uh we don't
have a planet
or a functioning society or many of the
other things
i think we are grappling with very much
this year and
and katie i know many of the companies
that are in your portfolio are focused
on
future proofing in a very literal way
we're trying to build things that ensure
that there is a future in which
we can make money as investors um and
uh actually i have an audience question
uh for you katie which is
sort of on those lines which is um
trying to get
policy makers to invest in
low probability high impact scenario
preparation so when we're thinking about
risk and how important it is to invest
in understanding those risks and
preparing for them how do you get policy
makers
to consider that as well well
you know i it's a great question and
it's something we spend a lot of time on
because
you know we don't have an educated
congress
about science and technology we only
have
three people in congress with a science
or technology degree
and uh they are woefully understaffed
in their understanding of what's
actually happening
and so and not because they're not good
people and
wouldn't want to set good policy for the
future i don't believe that at all
so that means that it's incumbent upon
you know people with that knowledge to
really
work with the folks that will set policy
and so there's a quite a large group of
people
that do that but it requires
really education i mean look at climate
change
we still have people negating that okay
so
california's burning people i mean that
was a real wake-up call
um look go to miami look at all the
basements they're flooded
the sea is rising there's there's no way
around
uh uh not acknowledging that yet
we still don't so you know we all
have to continue to educate those that
will make policy
but we also on the venture capital side
in the entrepreneurship
and innovation side have to also show
the way
what's the capital needed why is that
capital needed
how do you establish these industries
that will do good
and so you have to put forth and help
the policy makers
really see what's going on it's not
their fault that they don't know this
deep science
you know and so it's it's a
collaboration that needs to happen
yeah and i love this idea of modeling
that
through your investments and through the
work that you do um
we just have a couple of minutes left
but i did want to acknowledge that this
year has been a huge wake-up call
for not just issues of disaster
preparation but also arlen i know you're
seeing
um just as of this year a huge surge in
interest
around funding uh diverse founders black
and brown founders in particular
and so i was wondering if you could sort
of leave us with some thoughts about
how we take this energy into the future
and ensure that the founders and
companies that are underrepresented
right now are the ones that we're paying
more attention to
in the future what have you seen from
this year telling about
how we get more money into the hands
that need it
going forward yeah i think you know this
summer has just been very interesting
phone has been ringing off the hook in a
way that
as you know we haven't changed i haven't
changed but
uh circumstances have and to me it's
it's not a cause for celebration
obviously it's uh it's a very painful
time a traumatic time for
for so many people um and and
for me also time will tell you know this
can't be a moment it has to be a
movement and and
and it has to it has to stand the test
of time
because already i mean even already
there's been
i would say 40 to 60 percent drop off
in the interest since june because
people's
attention span and stamina is just so
lacking
when it comes to anything that's
uncomfortable or different or outside of
their comfort zone
and the the people who are still in the
fight the people even
large corporations some of them have
been able to stay in the fight
and really um you know beyond the
headlines and beyond the hoopla have
really said
what do we do and are learning from the
people who have been in the trenches
this whole time and we you know it it
wasn't a wake-up call by the way to
black people
this this what you're referring to it
was not a wake-up call to us we've been
woke for
the entire time so the people who were
jolted awake
really should um stay awake you know do
what it takes
um i won't call out a energy drink
because i don't know who your sponsors
are but do what it takes or make
stay awake and and make it a durable
sustainable
part of the fabric of your companies in
in internally
um and and that's you know that starts
internally too
with really looking at who you have on
your teams
how you're representing yourselves uh
outwardly how are you
how are people who are looking for jobs
um
do they feel included based on what they
see of your company so far
there's a lot that can be done and
there's so many people who already do
this work who you can tap
into rather than trying to reinvent the
will
i love that arlen katie i could talk to
you for another hour but unfortunately
that's all we have time for
but thank you so much for taking the
time today for being part of our wired25
and for sharing those insights thanks
hello everyone my name is matt simon i
am a science journalist at wired welcome
to the
wild 25 panel on big global
environmental challenges which sounds
very intimidating and a bit heavy
but i promise we're going to focus a lot
on some solutions here
and also on some very fascinating
research so with that i wanted to
introduce our panelists
first of all we have dee and steve allen
they are microplastic
researchers extraordinaire the dynamic
duo of microplastic research if i must
say
and isla meyer smith she is a global
change
ecologist thank you everybody for being
here today
thanks for having me sure
sure um stephen d you are on a boat
um and i i bring that up because it's
relevant last time we talked a few
months ago
you were in a caravan in the scottish
countryside
and i could hear sheep in the background
uh you're trotters
your globetrotters for very good reason
because of
the the what you're studying walk us
through what you're what you're doing
out there on boats and in caravans
well we survived the initial covid
lockdown in a caravan at a friend's
place with
many many sheep but now we've returned
to the middle of france on the rhone
river on
on our boat uh just uh waiting for all
the madness to stop so we can carry on
with the research
so what is it what is microplastics how
do you define that
um and i think it's a good way to start
to talk about your research
where are you finding these tiny bits of
plastic
um everywhere
so our research focuses on atmospherics
we went about looking up in the air
purely because we found
plastics in the oceans plastics has been
found
in the rivers in the river sediment it's
being found in
soil and we're still not finding that
mass
balance equality in the plastics that
we would expect so we have an idea of
how much is being thrown out how much is
being lost out of the waste management
system
but we don't know where that uh that
missing gap
is between the amount that we know is is
actually being put to waste and the uh
the amount that's being produced there's
a gap
so it's a leaky system we don't have a
circular economy and
we want to know where all of that
plastic has gone um and the last
environmental compartment to look at
is the atmosphere so we started looking
up in the atmosphere um
or in the air that's floating around you
all the time uh we started in france and
we've sort of moved globally to identify
where these microplastics might be
microplastic is a
slightly contentious term it depends on
who you talk to as to what size it is
it's basically anything that's under
five millimeters in size
all the way down to um one micron and
then below one micron
is a nanometer which is a nanoplastic
so that's not a medical definition
that's a scientific definition
yeah yeah and you know you're finding
these
these tiny bits of plastics on remo
mountain tops that it's very clear this
is blowing the wind and it's also
blowing up into the arctic
um it has been found in formerly
pristine areas up there and i think that
brings us uh
nicely to isla's research um also
looking at the the arctic but um looking
at some really troubling things when it
comes to
the climate change um given the fact
that the arctic is warming uh
twice if not more um faster than than
the rest of the planet so
i'll maybe just uh introduce your
research here and i i understand that
you actually have some
some new research that came out this
week that you could share
excellent yeah so uh i work in the
arctic and
in normal summers i'm actually up in the
arctic um for the last
uh or would have been for the last few
months uh collecting our field research
this summer's been a bit different but
the research continues this time more at
the computer
so i work in the canadian arctic and i
work with data sets from around the
arctic and what we're seeing is this
greening of tundra ecosystems so
you have the climate warming over the
last few decades and what we've been
doing is monitoring plants
on the ground and from the air using
drones and with my research team which
is called team shrub
tracking this change that's going on in
the high latitudes of the planet
and so we're using fixed swing plane
drones we're using the multi-copter
drones some of the
same kind of drone platforms that you
could buy commercially or fly yourself
and then we're monitoring these vast
tundra landscapes that have this green
surface of plants
at the top and what we're seeing from
space from satellites is this greening
pattern and what we're trying to figure
out on the ground is exactly what that
greening signal means in terms of
change on the ground and what that means
for the carbon cycle which is all a part
of this
global climate system and whether
basically warming in the arctic is going
to
amplify the climate change that we see
across the planet
yeah a couple things that i want to
follow up on um greening sounds
nice generally speaking but that is not
the case in the arctic um i
i was hoping you could um follow up on a
couple of maybe some knock-on effects
that we might be seeing
ecologically you know both in the arctic
itself but
looking at earth as an earth system um
how might the greening of the arctic
then
further feed into these patterns of
climate change
yeah so the vegetation we're seeing
vegetation change we're seeing in the
arctic is an
increase in the plants so you're up
above the tree line and where you are
in the arctic uh we have uh different
species that are sort of shorter than
trees but growing taller over time so
we've got these
shrubs in this system the woody plants
that are kind of the trees of the tundra
and then also grasses and other species
that can benefit when the
temperatures are warmer and the growing
seasons are longer so we think that's
what's causing
uh climate change in these systems and
that's kind of the theme of the new
paper that you mentioned before that
came out yesterday
we were working with higher resolution
satellite data and comparing that to
change on the ground and also the
warming patterns that we've seen in the
arctic
and in that paper we found that yeah
over 30 percent of the arctic is
greening so it is a really pervasive
signal
and we think that in some cases that's
trapping more
carbon in the plant but it's also
changing the arctic in different ways so
one way is as those shrub canopies get
taller that traps more snow in the
winter
and snow acts like a blanket in these
systems and it insulates the ground from
the cold temperatures in the air
in the winter time so it's kind of like
on a cold winter day if you put an extra
blanket on your bed you're warmer
and that's a problem because we don't
really want the soil to be warmer in
these systems
because that allows microbes to keep
munching away on the carbon that's in
there it allows the permafrost which is
the
permanently frozen ground to stay warmer
in the winter which means that in the
summer
it thaws to a deeper level and all of
that could potentially be releasing
carbon in the atmosphere
so what we're concerned about in these
systems as the vegetation increases
is that we might be seeing some positive
feedbacks that are going to release
carbon to the atmosphere and there's
quite a lot of carbon so i was trying to
look up
exactly how much carbon we're talking
about in these high latitude systems
and it's somewhere between 1 000 and 2
petagrams of carbon which uh nasa put
out this example so that's uh if you
imagine a coal train
and each of the coal train has these
cars full of coal and the coal is mostly
carbon
the train would be uh i think something
like 200 000 miles long
that's the amount of carbon that's in
the in the high latitudes that could be
released the atmosphere
so if it was released then that could as
much as
double the atmospheric co2
concentrations possibly more
and that would create this feedback that
means greater warming
not just in the arctic but for the
planet as a whole so the arctic's warm
by about two degrees already and we're
expecting it to warm by
six to ten degrees over the next 100
years maybe more
so all these feedbacks and this change
is already happening up there and we're
just trying to figure out
how fast and what it'll mean for all of
us on the planet
yeah yeah and speaking of feedback
stephen dia i think
um your research is particularly
fascinating because you're covering so
much
of the what we're starting to call the
microplastic cycle
the way that these particles are moving
between land and sea
and air um you know kind of building up
some of the stuff that i was talking
about these
these global systems that all
interconnected i was hoping you could
speak to
what we're learning about this
microplastic cycle how these little bits
of plastic are actually moving around
the planet
yeah i think we often forget that we
live on a ball
and that ball is inside a bubble so
there are no borders
nature doesn't see borders and certainly
pollution doesn't
so whatever we do in one area affects
everybody else
and plastic is a prime example of
covering long distances we're still
looking for the sources at the moment
um we're doing a lot of work on trying
to
pinpoint that so that we can try and
mitigate the problem
but uh yeah as as isler was mentioning
uh the amount of uh carbon in the
atmosphere is having an effect on the
arctic circle
and plastic of course is a uh
a producer of carbon the whole process
the whole life cycle of plastic
from taking the fracking gas out of the
ground turning into ethylene
from there all the way through to
landfill and this
imaginary recycling where it's actually
just being
shipped off to places like malaysia
where they either chop it up and burn it
or put it straight in the river
it's all every step along that route
is adding to the carbon footprint but
it's also
adding to points where it can leak out
into the environment
and that's where we're finding it in a
very very small material
so part of the work that we do looks at
how far it transports
and so we fight we can find where these
particles are
arriving in the world so we've got
samples from africa from
france we've got some samples from the
arctic we've got places uh we've got
we've got air samples from all over the
world
and everywhere you look you find plastic
though we haven't found a sample
that doesn't have any atmospheric
plastic and what you find falling
from the ground down to the ground and
what you find blowing through the air
are slightly different so they're a
slightly different particle size
they have slightly different dynamics
and shapes and the types of material
that they
are but what we can do is when we know
those those quantities and we know where
we found them we can then model
where this material goes so you do a
back trajectory model
and look at its history and if your
samples are taken in the right way
you can actually create a map saying i
caught this sample on this location so
we know that there's
there's pieces of plastic that we
potentially are breathing in that are on
this location so they're getting into
the ecosystems and we're getting into
lungs and things like that
in this location i've taken that sample
on that day i can then map
back where it's traveled through time in
the air
and there therefore where it came from
potentially so
there is moving forwards a way of not
finger pointing but like
identifying the key sources that can be
the major contributors to um
to what this atmospheric plastic is
yeah yeah um i i wanted to ask about
this we actually got a
question from a washer for of the the
series here that i think i just may well
kick to
um from laura tate um she was wondering
i think both of you can
ask us it's it's vague enough on a
planetary scale um
is it too late to save the planet um if
not what are the top three things we can
do to stop
the destruction of earth for our future
generations we're
we're closing out here in a couple of
last minutes um i hope we can end on a
bright night
in that way i hope we can
we're not going to
[Music]
um
there are some basic things we can do um
we
use an enormous amount of single-use
plastic
if you uh if you think about and you
value the plastic that you use on a
daily basis
in a different way so you identify this
as a very high value resource not
something that you use for a single
purpose and then dispose of
and if you stop using things in such
a a linear economy so you take it you
use it you throw it
then there is a potential to have a
substantial reduction on the amount of
plastic pollution that we could have in
this world it requires an awful lot of
change in the way that we create and we
manage our plastic but there is
positive things that you can do towards
it unfortunately the very small pieces
of plastic we have in our environment
we can't collect there is no mechanism
for us to filter the air in the world
and take all the plastic back out
so what's there we have to figure out
the damage it's doing
and the impact it's having and how not
to create more
um but we can't take that away
unfortunately
um and the same is sort of true for the
climate side of the equation so this is
a
a really big global problem and each of
us as individuals is playing a part in
that so we can
lower our own carbon footprints and as
scientists we can document the change
that's going on
um but we also need to work together as
a planet as different countries and
encourage our policy makers to really
think about enacting meaningful change
reducing carbon emissions and
part of our response as the climate
changes
is just to adapt ourselves and
and try to help these ecosystems along
as they adapt
to these warmer conditions so the arctic
is changing it's already changed but
that
doesn't mean that it's going to
necessarily change in ways that it'll be
unrecognizable in the future but
it could be different and we might need
to sort of adapt and deal with that new
different arctic and that new different
climate
system in the future
we so i had two minutes left just a
quick last question building off a
little bit of that
we hear a lot about things that we can
personally do um when it comes to
climate change and plastic pollution but
um neither of those are our problems as
individuals there
are corporations that have have done
this to a large degree
just very briefly if um if all three of
you might be able to
talk about um that context yes we can do
things individually
but we need to put pressure on the
bigger forces here
yeah i think uh the first thing you can
do is your vote
we need to influence the people who have
the power to make the changes
individually we can do small things to
you know lessen our plastic use but
really
it's got to come from the top we need
solid policy change plastic bag
bands and straw bands do not go far
enough
we need complete revolution in the
plastic industry for a start
labeling needs to be honest bioplastics
we need to prove they're safe before
they let them out
things like that really it's your vote
contact your politician tell them that
you care about this issue
and just building on that educate
yourself about the issues
find out about the arctic other parts of
the planet find out the changes that
different peoples around the world are
experiencing and share that information
and
maybe choose different purchases try to
buy local think about the food you eat
and the
traveling you're doing and try and yeah
limit your own impact on the planet
while sharing
um sort of the changes that are going on
and what we as a society can do
so and i agree definitely get out and
vote
okay i feel like we did the best we
could ending this on a rosy note given
the
uh the size of these problems um
but thanks to all three of you for being
here um
if any of the viewers are interested in
their research i've written extensively
about both of
the groups um here it's fascinating
stuff and we'll of course be covering
what you're doing
into the future um so uh have fun
sailing around the world
steve and dee um and isla thanks as well
for
for being here thank you thank you thank
you so much for having us
all right bye
hi everyone i'm sydney fusell i'm a
senior reporter for wired where i cover
big
data and policing i'm joined today by
matt mitchell he's a
ford foundation tech fellow and the
founder of crypto harlem where he works
active organizers on cyber security
threats and protecting themselves from
surveillance
hey how are you i'm good
i'm great awesome thanks so much for
taking the time to uh speak with us
could you tell us
just to start off a little bit about uh
crypto harlem
which doesn't have anything to do with
crypto kernels
yeah no i mean it doesn't have anything
to do with uh cryptocurrency um
that crypto stands for cryptography
although you know we we do teach
everything so we talked about you know
bitcoin and cryptocurrency and we have
experts come in like
rick dudley and things like that but um
crypto harlem started around the time of
the
george zimmerman um trayvon martin
trials
and i just felt like you know i wanted
to do something i went to work
and it just seemed like for the few
black folks at work
it was a horrible day but for a lot of
other people just a bad news day but it
was
it was really something that um really
changed
me and changed everyone who i was
speaking to my community harlem
and i wanted to do something so i
decided i'm a computer hacker i'm a
surveillance expert
i can at least talk to folks about the
surveillance in our neighborhood and how
it got there and how it works and how to
circumvent it and
the things that we can do to be safer
got it got it and i know that in your
work previously you
come up with this term digital stop and
frisk um can you tell us what a digital
stop and frisk is and how that relates
to your working people from surveillance
yeah i mean it's wild out here on these
digital streets and
you know we had stop and frisk in new
york and uh
that and that got um you know it didn't
get like
there's an idea that it doesn't exist
anymore and that it got like thrown out
or banned
limited use limited use right and
instead what we see is a lot of young
folks
are told by tech companies you know post
your information on twitter and facebook
and youtube and express yourself
and be you but for black folks in the
inner city
that is a way that you can get targeted
and um
law enforcement um works with companies
that can ingest
large amounts of social media traffic
and data do sentiment analysis
and try to you know use some ai to see
uh this
seems angry or this seems about that
create all kinds of networks and causal
uh connections and it ends up with uh
six in the morning seven in the morning
your door gets kicked in you get dragged
into the station with like hundreds of
other
uh young people right um so
there's a pretty well documented case
um of it in um in harlem or
where i live and um yeah i mean
there was a project crew cut and a bunch
of other police initiatives
where this happens and it happens to
this day you know we we see
um protesters in minneapolis um
protesters in other parts of the
of the country you know in um in
louisville
etc uh being targeted because of social
media posts
and yeah that's what digital stop and
frisk is it's the
criminalization of blackness but online
now instead of on the streets
and it's a lot harder to see it's a lot
harder to you know there's no one there
to like film this happening to you
and oftentimes it's delayed right
right and so is that your work with
crypto i don't know
people from these forms of you know
discrimination or digital surveillance
that's exactly what it is so you know a
lot of people just don't know that
that this is a thing right so um
they aren't aware that this is happening
they do see in their neighborhoods if
you go to the inner city from
you know south central to harlem you
know you go to chicago you go to miami
you're gonna find
uh technologies of surveillance in these
neighborhoods that you don't see outside
neighborhoods people aren't always
necessarily aware of what these things
look like what they do how they operate
and how it's used to criminalize their
behaviors and target them i mean
you know there was a bloomberg report on
uh um a persistent surveillance
company that has plans just kind of like
circling baltimore filming
live like what's going on i mean if you
live in that neighborhood you're on
camera when you go from place to place
and do things
and uh it's just you know i think we
need to have conversations about like
why this is and how it is and it becomes
like
it starts from being educated on it and
that's the first thing we do is educate
folks on like what's happening
and also you know what they can do
within their political rights within
their human rights
to push back against it
got it got it and i know you said the
sort of options of crypto harlem began
with george zimmerman and trayvon martin
but certainly
you know this summer beginning with the
george floyd protests we've seen a
huge groundswell of grassroots
organizations
you know smaller groups but also larger
ones like the aclu
and i was hoping to sort of speak to the
sort of bittersweetness of this moment
on the one hand you have
all these you know organizations and all
these people coming together and being
collective
but at the same time you also have a lot
of these you know negative groups that
are doing things like zoom bombing and
stuff like that
you know can you speak to how there's
like a lot of good and bad in this very
intense powerful moment
yeah i mean this is a global
movement and moment for civil rights and
racial justice not just in this country
but around the world
but let's not forget that this moment is
centered in
black pain and anxiety and um you know
it is bitter
because while there's a lot of attention
to these issues these are issues that
have been around for a very long time
you know surveillance of black
communities have
existed since the slave ships and uh
discontinued
methods of surveillance which are
methods of oppression have continued to
evolve
since then it's just gotten very
complicated you know if you live inside
the united states and you're exercising
your rights of free speech or your
rights to assembly your rights to
you know speak out against injustice and
protest and march and demonstrate
you might not realize that the entire
time for your use of social media
you're physically being at a protester
demonstration
there's a lot of data that you're
leaving there and it's being vacuumed up
and
used to uh you know used against you
right and i think marginalized people
in this country black and brown folks
queer folks anyone who's othered
are you know targets for this
criminalization of their behavior
in this moment of protest it's important
for folks to know
what they need to do and how they can
not only stay safe at a protest but
as they network and organize and try to
make positive things happen
absolutely and i think you're absolutely
right that there's a lot of
connections beginning with the very
foundation of america today
this month but you know again going back
to this moment beginning with the
historical test and the justice for
brianna taylor movement there are some
very specific
you know mind things that are being done
you have
different people from like reddit and
trolls and things like that doing
zumba we're trying to organize what are
the what are the threats of this current
you know like zoom everything
over the moment what are the things that
people can do to protect themselves
and be active and connect yeah 100
so you know in this moment a lot of
folks are maybe thinking about like law
enforcement or some intelligence agency
but
it could just be your neighbor or
someone who is part of your social
circle in real life or online it just
does not agree with your political views
and it doesn't take much for them to
disrupt your organizing what you're
trying to do
you know if you have a video conference
a live stream whatever it's like i'm
using
it's important for people to understand
like how to make that as limited
as possible to be disruptive right and
how to mitigate all kinds of attacks
like you know you're using zoom you got
zoom bombing
and you know that'll just ruin you
you're just beginning to start out a
grassroots
organization and everyone's so happy to
be there and then all of a sudden you
have trolls
attacking you and doxing people by
posting their personal identifiable
information online
the things that you can do are to send
obviously there's some basic things like
send that invite
to as trusted a list as you can and at
as short a notice as you can you can
have people rsvp
for the event but only send the link to
people who rsvp'd at a certain time
but then in the technologies they create
things where you know
people don't just get thrown into a room
together they have to be held in some
place or
in a waiting room or things like that
and these are all features that
uh it's important for if you're going to
organize and use any technology
it's important for you to take a look at
all these different privacy and security
sections the first thing you want to
jump into and turn that those things on
you want to turn off any kind of
personalization and ads
and you also want to look into what is
this technology's
record um of fighting for people's
rights who use it so
that's always in this little privacy
statement that we always skip right
it's really important to take a look at
that and read it over time
because this is real
got it and then you know we're wrapping
up but you did say something to me the
other day that that was fascinating
which was the canaries are screaming so
just with the last you know minute or so
that we have
left what did you mean by that and what
is the sort of message you want people
to take away in terms of what they can
do going forward
yeah i mean look when you look at
anywhere in the world you look at any
space in the world you know there are
people who are close to the seats of
power
and the people who are like centered the
masses the dominant culture whatever you
want to call that
and the people on the margins who are
pushed out there they don't want to be
there
they're pushed out by like a centrifugal
force of that
you know community or culture or country
or wherever it is
you know they are the canaries when it
comes to surveillance they're the ones
who are targeted first they're other
first
beta testers for a lot of technologies
you'll see it where those people gather
for
for prayer or worship or for food or
where they live and um it's there where
we have to fight because
otherwise the momentum will be stacked
against us so we're going to push back
against things like facial recognition
or we're gonna push back against things
like you know weaponizing ai to
attack democracies um it begins in black
communities and brown communities
and in marginalized communities they're
the canaries in the coal mine and they
are screaming but we're still alive
yes we are absolutely well matt thank
you so much for taking the time to
uh speak with us today here on wired25
and thank you for the work that you're
doing please continue to
protect us and keep us safe as we as we
organize and do everything we can
thank you it's honor thank you sydney
thanks matt
mr president is it important that people
be afraid of you
fear
hello and welcome i'm maria rasa
mariaresa
carries the torch of press freedom in a
country held in thrall
by a populist president it started with
the drug war
do not do drugs because i
will kill you president duterte began
his administration
with the drug list this is the drug
industry of the philippines he
showed everyone a list people on that
list started dying
i'm telling the filipino people it's
going to be
bloody we demanded the government be
held accountable
duterte was annoyed by our reporting
you are a fake news outlet you will be
allowed to criticize us
but you go to jail for your crime we
started getting an attack on social
media
the government created disinformation
networks so people have no idea what the
truth is
i was getting an average of 98 messages
per hour
we don't even know whether we can trust
the police to protect us
we didn't even realize how dangerous it
is for you
why are you crying because i'm scared to
freak out
maria ressa has been arrested the
charges against russell were aimed at
intimidating those who
challenge duterte's rule
[Music]
[Applause]
so why should you care about what
happens in the philippines
they test the tactics of how to
manipulate america
in our country if it works they port
it over to the rest of the world
maria was one of four journalists named
as time magazine's person of the year
maria won't be afraid i'm
afraid for him what we're seeing
is death by a thousand cuts little cuts
of philippine democracy
we will not duck we will not hide
we will hold the line
[Music]
hi i'm so honored to welcome maria ressa
uh
the ceo and executive editor of rappler
to wired25
uh i watched that documentary just last
night and it's fantastic i suggest
uh people look it up you could watch it
and stream it from your local movie
theater
maria thanks so much for doing this
especially since it's way past midnight
manila time isn't it
it is but a thrill to be with you steve
well thanks it's uh marie and i i've met
and it's been great to
get to know her during this tumultuous
time in her life
now i know rappler has actually been in
the news this week and i want to talk
about that
but first i want to talk about uh the
viewers just saw you
getting arrested um what is the
situation now
with the various
arrests and in one case a conviction
that
you've had to deal with from that
charming uh gentleman
mr duterte that we just saw in that clip
uh so i have eight arrest warrants right
so
eight criminal charges and they're
fallen to three buckets uh
cyber libel uh i was arrested for that
um
uh tax evasion in order to
to file these tax evasion charges the
government actually
recalc renamed rappler were no longer a
news group were a dealer in securities
so that's how we now have five tax
evasion cases against us
uh and then the last one is kind of the
mother case securities fraud
uh where are they well look i have a
filing almost every week i still spend a
big chunk of my time
maybe 80 to 90 depending on which week
it is
on legal cases just this week monday
i was supposed to testify to fight for
my right to travel um
that didn't happen in fact the
government tried to expunge
my anyway this is all still ongoing
uh and i guess the only thing i can say
is we keep
fighting every step of the way i fight
for my rights
i fight for rappler's rights it is a
press freedom issue and the
legal acrobatics to bring us there well
i guess the one word
to describe all of it and i think about
this all the time now as um
i feel like joseph k in the trial it's
kafkaesque
you know i i i thought about that when i
just read about the way particularly
that cyber libel case
went through you know tell us like a
little bit about it because it just
seems so incredibly dicey
you know how they brought that
particular case against you
so uh i was convicted along with a
former colleague
ray santos he no longer works for us he
actually went to work for government
after he left raptor right so
we were convicted on june 15th and i i
could go to jail for up to six years
for a story that i that was
written eight years ago that i didn't
write
didn't edit had no had no supervision
over it
for uh violating supposedly violating a
law
that didn't exist at the time that we
published it
and in order to even get us there this
cyber libel
uh law to get us to court they actually
had to change the statute of limitations
of libel from one year to 12 years
and then also come up with a novel uh
interpretation of republication for
digital all of these redefinitions will
have an impact on filipinos
who are posting on social media now they
can be sued for libel for up to 12 years
having said that
we are appealing it and i have you know
two levels of appeals to go
uh up to the supreme court i i i won't
give up
right and you told me uh recently the
total
of possible jail time that you could
serve for this is what
all the eight cases that we're facing
you know and and it took
uh the international lawyers it took a
mall to actually
tell me how many it's almost 100 years
total cumulative sentences of these
eight criminal charges
i hope i i stay alive that long
that's a that's incredible i do laugh i
do laugh about it now because
you know it's almost i guess it's kind
of gallows humor how do you deal with it
it's unbelievable and you i just i laugh
how do you deal with it actually just
laughing i mean that there's there's
there's
more to it than that there's some
emotional moments in that documentary
and
you know every time i see you you're
always so upbeat
and every time i leave leave a man
talking to you
i'm about to slash my wrists because
it's so disturbing what's happened to
you
[Music]
i guess so you play
with your own fear it's in your head and
i just remember that
all the time and that and we talk
amongst ourselves
in our team right so how do i i think of
the worst case
scenario of whatever it is and then i
imagine how i would deal with it
i embrace my fear and if i if i really
hold it tight then i can rob it of its
power
over me and this goes to everything this
is also kind of the way that i run
rapper right we have to embrace our fear
and then go beyond that we work flow our
responses to our fear so what's the
worst case scenario
let's figure it out break it down and
then drill it
like for example in in the film you see
pia renata our reporter
at the palace she chase she follows
duterte
followed until we were banned anyway she
we had actually just drilled right a few
days before
she was banned from the palace what she
what we should all do
if we get harassed or if if
uh if you're prevented access and we had
it down to it
pulling out your cell phone what things
needed to be set up on your cell phone
and how many steps does it take for you
to go live and you go live and
you know one of the things she told us
after that was that when
when it happened she had just drilled it
like a day or so before earlier and it
worked
so that's it it's like i guess it's
games with yourself as well
because the world is doing things you
can't control
so you figure out what you can control
which is yourself
wow so let's talk about this week's news
that raptor was involved in so
yesterday facebook's head of security
nathan gleicher
announced that facebook has shut down
some accounts
pages and groups originating from china
so we all heard about the russian
interference with you know the american
election and before that in ukraine
and it looks like china is now uh taking
a page from that and getting involved
in messing with other countries uh
elections and governance
and one of the people who they were
backing taking uh
just like they backed trump in america
was duterte the
leader of the the philippines who is
your prosecutor um and you've
investigated him
um now did rappler had a hand in in
locating this these groups these
organized groups to circulate muslim
information didn't they
can you tell us about that uh so
facebook about this time uh 24 hours ago
they announced that they would take down
two influence operations and what i mean
by influence operations is you know
state in this particular case both look
state sponsored but
you know you you in in a closed system
you feed lies
you and the end goal of all of that is
to change the minds to change the way
people think so they change the way they
act
in there were two the first was chinese
influence
operations they originated from fujian
and then the second were philippine
domestic influence operations that were
linked by facebook to the police and
military
we had a hand uh in the in the domestic
one the police and military because
we were quite alarmed by the inciting
to hate inciting to violence against
human rights activists lawmakers
journalists
and and given the anti-terror law that
was just passed where anyone designated
a terrorist can be arrested
without a warrant and held for up to 24
days
we felt that you know the brought this
up we did the stories
and then brought it up to facebook i
think the second one the chinese
operations are interesting for me
because we started seeing these accounts
filtering in
a year ago and uh and one of the
interests of course you can look at the
report now but
it shows you that this network the
chinese
influence operations were focused not
just on the philippines but on
southeast asia taiwan indonesia they
were most successful
in the philippines and in the
philippines they were pro-duterte
pro-marcos they focused on content on
the south china sea which is deeply
contentious
and then finally of course this is a
network that attacked
me personally i mean it's kind of good
to know that
well we knew this from the data but i
was just going to be glib and say
so now china comes in to also join the
attacks that are state-sponsored
here so it is exactly what we have seen
from four years ago
is just as usual from russian
disinformation it spreads
chinese this information is now
evolved has been affected by that and
that you know
while it's great that facebook took it
down there is a lot more
that needs to be taken down one one
thing that was interesting
that uh came out from facebook i think
um in his post glacier said
it wasn't the content of the posts
which you know violated facebook policy
but just the idea that
they were from these inauthentic
networks so basically some of the
content just
attacked you directly and what he was
saying is gee that that that's okay you
think after all this time
facebook would maybe you know
look at their policies and say is it
okay for a policy
to be personally attacking you know uh
not just from you know prominent
journalists like yourself but anyone
with with such lies
is it these parts of discussions that
you've had with facebook
yeah yeah stephen i mean you know your
book
actually shows all of the difficulties
that facebook has had with this
i think that they continue to dock
responsibility
as a publisher they don't want to be
called a publisher even though
in a way they are i mean to all intents
and purposes
facebook is the world's largest
distributor of news right but
look the reason we at rappler also
don't just look at the content because
that's a whack-a-mole
game right and it's much easier to think
about it
the work that we did with
counter-terrorism before
actually helped infuse the way we
gathered data
and the way we look at networks of
disinformation
because i don't want to get distracted
by
misinformation and i also wonder why
americans always use
misinformation versus disinformation it
is
very clear there are networks that are
meant uh
to manipulate us and those are the ones
like
terrorism we should take down so that's
kind of
the way facebook has dealt with the
network is they they came up with this
this you know this um definition cib
coordinated inauthentic behavior right
but the problem is that this definition
maybe would have worked
four years ago in 2016 when the
information ecosystem the influence
operations coming in
uh started right well it started earlier
than that
it started in 2014 but anyway uh
now four years into it right
like in the philippines it's the attacks
are constant for four years
these types of exponential when lies
laced with anger and hate spread faster
and further than facts
those lies are part of these information
operations they change the way people
think so four years later
real people think this now i mean real
accounts
so how do you deal with that i think
that's a failure in terms of
how facebook thinks about this because
the influence operations
have fundamentally changed the ecosystem
democracy
is weaker everywhere around the world
including in your country
yeah i want to i want to talk about that
in a second um and we
we've certainly seen that it's an attack
on truth
but since the philippines are a little
ahead of this on this
i wonder as a journalist you do this
great investigative journalism
but does it get to a point where
the audiences that you want to present
that
journalism to just won't be affected by
it because
they won't believe anything
and that's the goal and i think we are
there this is the problem
this is and that's the root that's the
core of russian disinformation right and
that i think was a basic understanding
that facebook didn't have i mean they
brought in a lot of people in 2018 but
it was quite late in the game
i mean the attacks against me began in
2016.
um journalist equals criminal right and
look at how
it went where it went in 2020 there are
filipinos who believe i'm a criminal and
yet i haven't done anything differently
but the information ecosystem was
fundamentally changed by social media
platforms
so um yeah so the goal of russian
disinformation
is not to make you believe in anything
but to destroy
your trust in everything and that
includes why are journalists attacked
why are news organizations attacked
because we
bring the facts we still hold power to
account i would say in the last four
years
the journalists have done their jobs we
continue to do that
even when it's become far more dangerous
to do so
same in the united states right but the
problem is that when the information
ecosystem is
so chaotic and when the distribution
system prioritize lies
over facts prioritizes anger and hate
over rational thinking then you know you
you're left with a with a democracy
where people can't tell fact from
fiction
that means you don't have facts you
can't have
truth you can't have trust how can you
have a democracy if you have no
integrity of facts
how can you have integrity of markets
and then
how can you have integrity of elections
right so having said that this is
we saw the reports start to come out the
research reports start to come out as
early as
2017 and you know we felt
the attacks in 2016. so globally in 2017
i think it was freedom house that said
that
in at least 27 countries around the
world cheap armies on social media was
rolling back democracy
a year later in 2018 that was almost
doubled by oxford university's
computational propaganda research
project and then in 2019
it was more than 72 countries and who
knows right
what we've seen with the coronavirus is
that power has consolidated power
they're automatically given greater
power because of the virus
and in countries like mine hungary
lots brazil all of a sudden government
gets authoritarian style populist
leaders
get far more power and far more money
so in 2016 it's something uh answered
that i tell
in in my book um facebook the inside
story
uh you warned facebook about this you
said this is happening
right now in the philippines um
and it could be happening in the united
states it could even elect donald trump
and everyone laughed because that seems
so
absurd uh do you feel that
in that time because there was a few
years that facebook had been getting
these complaints
facebook understood it and was turning a
blind eye
or they hadn't understood it at that
point
and the second part of the question
would be do they really understand it
now
so i think in 2016 they didn't
understand it because the so you you
know this better actually stephen i
should ask you
they put the growth people in charge
right
you would know that better they put
engineers who were
and the word is optimizing so they were
optimizing
to manipulate us to keep us on the
platform
uh and and also optimizing for money
the micro targeting you know i actually
always say that
uh today these social media platforms
are behavior modification systems
because they take everything we put in
they use machine learning to build the
models of us
and then they take our most vulnerable
moment to a message
and they sell that to the highest bidder
that micro targeting makes it extremely
potent
and that bidder can be a government
or a company and i i don't think this is
advertising in the old sense anyway i'm
sorry i got derailed but
um here i guess the first
part of that is that um in 2016 they may
not have known completely but they got
repeated
uh warnings i was very personal
i gave them excel sheets of stuff
and the conversation that you've talked
about was in 2016.
in 2017 i did get to talk to mark
zuckerberg to sheryl sandberg
i i brought up that the philippines in
fact i invited mark to come visit the
philippines to see how powerful
facebook is facebook is our internet
100 percent you know
did he take up your invitation
the way he dealt with it was you know he
he was just starting the travel through
the us
because he was just realizing how little
he knew right
he's a he's you know this better than i
because you sat in
so many uh interviews with him but you
know he struck me as a bright
young man young because i'm much older
than he you know but
bright but had never lived outside the
united states and
you know i told him i said mark 97 at
that point was 97
of filipinos on the internet are on
facebook facebook is our internet
and then he just looked at me and this
was like maybe about
10 10 or 11 no more than a dozen of us
uh and and then he he just said wait
wait maria
where are the other three percent well
he got the other three percent
in the succeeding years and i laughed at
that point in time but now it's just
look looking at these influence
operations
this is insidious manipulation of us and
i guess that's my question is how can we
do we have free will that's one the
second is you know and this
is something that the chinese influence
operations do
they were the the posts that they
posted against me were inciting hate
inciting hate inciting violence
degrading you so that you're not a human
being these things are extremely
dangerous
and we've seen the violence erupt in
countries like
myanmar where the u.n sent a special a
fact-finding group
and facebook sent its own and they
determined
that genocide happened gosh
you know stephen we can talk about so
many things
yeah i i guess let me ask you apology
i'm hopeful me well
i mean i'm i'm disturbed i'm disturbed
of what's happening in the philippines
and in america but i want to
say asking something positive we have a
question from our audience
that you know maybe we could you know
finish on more of an upbeat note so what
is
and justin slutsky asks what is an
achievable
positive change that could be made in
the world
in the next five years
so i'm going to so many things that i
would love to happen but if i could like
wave a magic wand you know enlighten
self-interest for facebook
it's so strange because i was just
talking to some of the folks there
you know they have tremendous power but
it's the abdication
of the use of the power they don't want
it marcus said this
you don't want facebook being the
arbiter of free speech
like i feel every time i hear that and
every time i hear a facebook rep say
that i always think
good god get over yourselves you already
are and the choices that you have
made have destroyed democracy and put
people like me in
extreme danger and has killed people
because the problem is that the global
south
our countries are the ones that bear the
brunt of silicon valley's decisions
so a positive thing number one
i guess facebook is asking for
regulations
regulations take time i hope enlightened
self-interest happens that facebook
does things like what it just did 24
hours ago
take down these networks of
disinformation
that are fomenting hate that are
spreading lies that are meant
to kill democracy that's that's one uh
and it isn't just facebook
it's these kinds of designs the kind the
algorithms that that create a loop that
manipulate us
these things are embedded in every
social media platform right it's just
facebook is the world's largest
distributor of news
i think that's that's one um the second
is
can the world please come together we're
watching the un general assembly on the
75th
year right but 75 years ago the atom
bomb went off the end of world war ii
the end of fascism
and now it looks like we're on the cusp
of returning to fascism if we
cannot uh solve this problem that was
created by moving fast and breaking
things right so
you know i you know we talk about this
all the time because i go stephen please
tell me give me hope
i have a lot of i put a lot of
hope and faith still in facebook we
can't put the genie
back in the bottle and i'm just hoping
that they move fast enough and do not
wait for legislation
having said that they ask for it so yes
we need laws
we need to come together beyond the laws
and treat it like we did post world war
ii
the world came together to prevent
humanity from destroying itself
and that's when we created the u.n the
u.n declaration of human rights
right so this is another one of those
moments we need to do this
and this protects our lives and our
democracies
well i i asked you for positive you gave
me atom bombs and fascisms
but you are the inspiration
anyway i want to thank you so much uh
you can go to sleep now
uh and you know uh wired 25
thanks you and best of luck to you
to youtube thanks
well that was fascinating thank you
stephen thank you maria
and in that conversation i was reminded
of something that
was a thread through all of the
conversations today and it's one of the
things that interests me most about
technology and is that in technology and
science there's frequent
compounding right ms marie resta said
power consolidates
power because of network effects because
of economies of scale
when something starts moving in one
direction it tends to
move ever faster in that direction right
authoritarian governments overwhelm
social networks which helps empower
authoritarian governments
which can then overwhelm social networks
climate change leads to changes in the
biology of the arctic
it leads to more climate change leads to
more changes in the biology of the
arctic
ecosystem
a vc ecosystem with a narrow focus
narrows the focus of the vc
ecosystem so what tends to happen is if
things start going in the wrong way
they continue that way but what's
interesting and what's important about
this conversation is that the reverse
is also true when things start getting
better
when democracy becomes empowered things
can start going in the right direction
with the same compounding effects the
same economies of scale
so that's one of the great things about
tech if you can set things
in the right direction things get
whatever and so that's what i felt like
was the biggest theme
of the conversations today people
working as hard as they could
to make things go in the right direction
again
so thank you to everybody who spoke
thank you to our fabulous wired
moderators and thank you to our sponsor
vonage
bono just bringing people together
globally and thanks to their support
helping us create a richer wired 25
experience
we've now done two out of three the last
one is next wednesday
it's all about the wired superheroes of
2020.
so we call the scientists hackers
journalists policymakers
really protecting us during the pandemic
so
we'll hear from dr anthony fauci you
probably know who he is you can check
twitter if you want to see his latest
and greatest conversations with rand
paul
we'll hear from audrey tang taiwan's
digital minister
taiwan has a dense population it's about
25 larger than new york
and they suffered seven deaths from
coronavirus
and that's partly thanks to the work of
tang and
of open democracy and digital democracy
we'll also hear from the cti league of
volunteer hackers defending the health
care sector
coveted exploiting cyber criminals we're
gonna hear from journalist patrice peck
newsletter coronavirus news for black
folks
we're gonna talk to the 17 year old who
built a coronavirus tracker
we've talked to people securing our
elections we'll wrap up the day
with a timely session about the fires in
the western united states
and what we can do about them afterwards
we'll also do deeper dives with speaker
meetups after the program so stay tuned
for those they'll be announced on monday
registered attendees will be able to
pick the ones they want to go to
if you signed up for a speaker meetup
today
zooms are starting right now topics are
documenting the canaries in our
environmental coal mine
virtual reality fosters actual empathy
and what's the difference between
fortnite and facebook from the ux
strategy
so thank you so much we'll see you next
week
[Music]
[Applause]
you